vous aimez les questions
parce que moi j'aime bien ça se poser
des questions existentielles comprendre
le monde qui nous entoure se comprendre
soi-même je sais pas ça et ben justement
ça va être l'objet de ce nouveau format
qui s'appelle est-ce que ça se peut le
concept c'est hyper facile on se pose
toutes et tous ensemble des questions
sur le corps humain les maladies etc etc
la santé quoi et après moi j'y réponds
je vais vous expliquer ça un petit peu
mieux après le générique
[Musique]
bon donc est-ce que ça se peut à quoi ça
va ressembler je vais vous donner un
exemple ça sera plus simple est-ce que
ça se peut d'avoir trois bras alors oui
ça se peut c'est même arrivé pas plus
tard que cette année au Rajasthan et un
état du Nord-Ouest de l'Inde une petite
fille est née avec un troisième bras
dans le dos ça s'appelle une Polynésie
ah oui alors petit truc parfois je vais
mettre des photos des cas ou des gens
dont je suis en train de parler pour
éviter de choquer les gens qu'on part
envie de voir ça avant de mettre la
photo je mettrai ce son
comme ça vous pourrez fermer les yeux et
après quand j'aurai enlevé l'image je le
mettrai ce son on va faire une
démonstration tout de suite
voilà donc ça c'est la petite fille en
question vous voyez son troisième
braille c'est pas complètement développé
mais il est là voilà bon je pense que
vous avez compris le principe mais je
vais quand même vous donner un autre
exemple pour être sûr qu'on est bon
est-ce que ça se peut de soigner des
maladies avec de l'eau et un peu de
sucre alors non il y en a qui ont essayé
il y en a même qui essaye encore à
l'heure actuelle ils se font un paquet
de tunes mais ça n'a jamais soigné
personne une hypoglycémie à la limite
mais pas plus allez un dernier petit
exemple est-ce que ça se peut que cette
vidéo soit sponsorisée par un cognit bah
oui ça se peut parce que figurez-vous
que cette vidéo est sponsorisée par un
colis
bon je vous explique quand vous vous
baladez sur Internet vous voyez ces
fenêtres là qui s'ouvrent tout le temps
et qui vous demande de faire des
réglages pour les cookies et que vous
refermez en cliquant sur tout accepter
parce que vous avez pas le temps je juge
pas je fais pareil et bah du coup il y a
plein de sites d'applis etc qui
récupèrent vos données personnelles et
qui font on sait pas trop quoi avec bon
en fait si on sait ce qu'ils font avec
il les revendent à des gens qui vous
cassent après en blindant votre boîte
mail de spam en vous appelant cinq fois
par jour pour vous vendre des fenêtres
ou en vous envoyant des sms pour des
histoires de CPF ou de vignettes
réglementaires pour votre voiture alors
que vous avez même pas de voiture vous
voyez non et dites-vous qu'ils ont aussi
plein d'autres infos sur vous comme
votre adresse IP votre adresse tout
court vos infos financières les trucs
que vous achetez etc etc et ben voilà
c'est là qu'un Connie intervient il
vérifie toutes les listes sur lesquelles
vous apparaissez et ils font le
nécessaire pour vous retirer de là si
vous voulez prendre un abonnement pour
qu'il fasse ça régulièrement parce que
bien sûr on va tout et tous continuer à
cliquer sur tout accepter vous avez un
lien dans la description qui vous permet
d'avoir 60% de réduction sur un
abonnement annuel allez est-ce que ça se
peut de naître sans cerveau oui donc là
vous vous dites ok donc on commence par
une facile je sais à quoi vous pensez
mais c'est pas ça pas du tout ceci dit
vous avez raison ça se peut de naître
son cerveau c'est pas drôle du tout
naître son cerveau ça s'appelle être
annoncéphale là dans céphalie C'est
quand on n'a pas d'hémisphère Céré ça
c'est les deux grosses masses là qui
sont collées qu'on appelle le cerveau
même si en vrai il y a d'autres trucs
qui en font partie mais comme on les
voit moins on en parle moins donc dans
la dansecéphalie il y a pas du tout
d'hémisphère cérébraux ou alors il y en
a très très peu cette malformation elle
arrive parce que pendant la grossesse
pour des raisons qu'on s'explique pas
encore complètement il y a un truc qui
s'appelle le tube neural qui se referme
pas correctement je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez on avait déjà un peu parlé
de ça dans la vidéo sur le carnet de
santé de Frida Kahlo parce qu'elle avait
un spina-bifida qui vient du même
problème sauf que dans ce cas là ça
touche pas le cerveau mais l'autre
l'extrémité c'est à dire le bas de la
colonne vertébrale le mieux c'est que
vous retournez voir la vidéo je veux pas
dans le cas de l'annoncéphalie en plus
du cerveau il manque aussi de la boîte
crânienne les os du crâne si vous voulez
il s'arrête en général juste au dessus
des sourcils donc les bébés
annoncéphales ont une apparence très
significative et oui je parle de bébé
seulement parce que ceux qui en sont
atteints ne survivent pas plus de
quelques heures voire quelques jours à
l'exception notable du petit Jackson
Buell qui est né avec une annoncéphalie
partielle et qui a survécu jusqu'à ses 5
ans voilà donc comme je vous l'ai dit là
dans céphalie c'est une maladie rare et
on sait pas exactement quel en est la
cause est-ce que ça se peut de naître
sans cœur bah non ça se peut pas
on peut survivre si il nous manque une
partie du cerveau mais sans cœur pas de
circulation sanguine et sans circulation
sanguine pas de vie par contre en 2017
il y a une petite fille du nom de
vanelope Wilkins qui est né au
Royaume-Uni avec le coeur à l'extérieur
de la poitrine les médecins sont sombres
quand elle était encore dans le ventre
de sa mère ils ont décidé de faire une
césarienne pour pas risquer d'abîmer le
cœur et une partie de l'estomac qui
était aussi à l'extérieur et moins d'une
heure après sa naissance le bébé était
au bloc opératoire pour replacer son
cœur à l'intérieur de son thorax vous
vous doutez bien qu'une opération aussi
lourde sur un aussi petit bébé c'est pas
gagné d'avance et que la convalescence
elle va être longue mais 14 mois plus
tard la petite vanelope a pu rentrer
chez elle définitivement et s'installer
pour de bons dans sa chambre le fait
d'avoir le cœur en dehors du thorax
c'est une malformation congénitale qui
s'appelle une ectopie cardiaque c'est
très rare et ça peut arriver soit comme
ça de manière isolée soit accompagné
d'autres symptômes comme dans le cas de
la pentalogie de Cantrel ce syndrome il
y a une jeune russe qui vit aux
États-Unis pour suivre des soins qui
s'appelle virsavia Borun gonecharva qui
en est atteinte son cas est assez connu
parce que en 2015 sa mère avait lancé
une cagnotte pour la faire opérer mais
finalement on s'est rendu compte que son
cœur était trop fragile pour supporter
l'opération du coup depuis elle vit sa
vie comme ça normalement il faut juste
qu'elle fasse extrêmement attention de
pas prendre de coups au niveau du thorax
est-ce que ça se peut d'avoir des poils
sur la langue oui bon arrêtez 2 secondes
ça va je vous vois vous savez je parle
d'avoir ses propres poils à soi sur la
langue enfin ça veut dire des poils à la
langue des poils la langue poilue quoi
si vous voulez est-ce que ça se peut
d'avoir la langue poilue bah oui ça peut
regardez-moi un petit peu cette langue
avec tous ces petits poils la vie est
trop courte pour s'épiler la langue
après tout mais comment c'est possible
d'avoir des poils qui poussent sur la
langue et bah la vérité c'est que ok
cette maladie elle s'appelle la maladie
de la langue poilue ou la maladie de la
langue velue mais qu'en fait c'est pas
vraiment des poils c'est une maladie qui
aurait été découverte au 16e siècle et
depuis bah on cherche encore à tout bien
comprendre les poils qui apparaissent
sur la langue dans ces cas-là ils sont
noirs en général mais parfois ils
peuvent aussi avoir une autre couleur
genre bleu rouge jaune ou même vert
déjà avoir la langue poilue ça devrait
être super facile à vivre tout le temps
alors en plus des poils verts en même
temps je suis daltonien donc je sais
même pas de quoi je me mêle bon mais
alors vu que c'est pas vraiment des
poils qu'est-ce que c'est et ben notre
langue normalement elle se nettoie toute
seule et ça muqueuse se renouvelle un
peu comme toutes nos cellules sauf que
parfois pour des raisons que là encore
on connaît pas toujours très bien et ben
ça foire il y a bien des nouvelles
cellules qui se créent mais les
anciennes elles s'en vont pas du coup il
y a de la kératine vous savez c'est une
protéine qu'on a sur la peau les ongles
les cheveux les poils etc donc il y a de
la kératine qui s'accumule sur nos
papilles ces petits trucs là en relief
qu'on a sur la langue et qui nous
permettent par exemple de sentir le goût
de ce qu'on mange
vous voyez du coup tout ça toutes ces
cellules elle s'entassent elles
s'entassent les unes sur les autres et
ça finit par donner des petits filaments
qui ressemblent à des poils et ça prend
des couleurs différentes en fonction de
tout ce qu'il y a autour comme bactéries
et compagnie alors c'est sûrement pas
ouf à vivre comme expérience mais ça
soigne ça se guérit bien sans avoir
besoin de prendre des ou chez
l'esthéticienne je veux dire est-ce que
ça se peut de vivre jusqu'à 160 ans vous
connaissez Jeanne Calment ça
m'étonnerait parce qu'elle est morte en
97 quand même elle était française et
c'est officiellement la personne qui a
vécu le plus longtemps avec ses 122 ans
mais vu que l'espérance de vie augmente
tous les ans
non je déconne vous pouvez ouvrir les
yeux enfin je déteste les courbes perso
donc si vous voulez refermer les yeux je
vais pas vous voyez ça monte ça monte
même assez significativement du coup
avec les progrès de la médecine en plus
on peut se dire que d'ici quelques
dizaines centaines d'années on pourra
vivre jusqu'à 160 en facile sauf qu'il y
a une étude publiée en 2021 qui estime
qu'on a une date de péremption et qui
conclut que ok ce qui nous tue c'est des
maladies des accidents etc mais que de
toute façon nos cellules nos organes etc
tout ça ça décline et que d'après leurs
calculs c'est pas fait pour fonctionner
plus de 120 150 ans maximum tout ça ça
empêche pas que depuis un certain nombre
d'années maintenant il y a des
milliardaires qui financent des
recherches pour essayer d'allonger
l'espérance de vie voir atteindre
l'immortalité Jeff Bezos par exemple
[Musique]
le boss d'Amazon et ben il finance un
laboratoire qui s'appelle altoslavs et
dans ce labo on cherche à ralentir voir
à inverser le vieillissement des
cellules autre exemple Google il héberge
une entreprise de biotechnologie dont le
but avoué est de tuer la mort
une étude prédictive scientifique d'un
côté les milliardaires de la Silicon
Valley de l'autre qui va gagner bon je
pense que de toute façon aucun d'entre
nous sera là pour voir ça ou alors il va
falloir aussi financer de quoi contrer
les effets du dérèglement climatique
parce que sinon est-ce que ça se peut de
mourir de rire alors autant vous le dire
tout de suite oui on peut mourir de rire
quand je travaillais au SAMU par exemple
j'ai eu le cas d'un monsieur un peu âgé
qui s'est étouffé en mangeant à cause
d'un forêt il y a un morceau de steak
qui s'est coincé dans sa trachée ça
s'appelle faire une fausse route il
pouvait plus respirer et le temps qu'on
arrive malheureusement c'était trop tard
petit truc en passant formez-vous au
gestes qui sauvent là en l'occurrence la
manœuvre de heimlich ça aurait sauvé la
vie du monsieur ou alors balancez pas
vos meilleures blagues à table non mais
en vrai formez-vous
il y a aussi des exemples dans
l'histoire de gens qui sont morts de
rire il y a Pietro arettino par exemple
un écrivain italien du XVIe siècle qui
serait mort de rire en tombant
littéralement de sa chaise après une
bonne grosse blague bien salace a priori
c'est quand même une légende mais
admettons que ça peut arriver alors vous
allez me dire oui mais là c'est la
fausse route et la fracture du crâne qui
tue pas le rire ah ben vous avez raison
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise mais le problème quand on tape une
bonne barre de rire c'est que c'est
éprouvant physiquement il y a énormément
de muscles qui rentrent en jeu le
diaphragme par exemple oui c'est un gros
muscle qui vide les plus longs quand ils
se contractent et vu que le rire c'est
un réflexe donc on peut pas le contrôler
ça peut arriver que le diaphragme il se
contracte très fort plusieurs fois
d'affilée et que ça soit difficile de
reprendre son souffle et la contraction
de tous les différents muscles plus les
soufflements ça charge aussi la barque
d'un autre muscle le cœur donc une
grosse grosse crise de rire chez une
personne un petit peu fragile soit au
niveau respiratoire soit au niveau
cardiaque soit au niveau des vaisseaux
soit les trois
oui ça peut poser problème encore plus
si vous avez ce qu'on appelle un rire
pathologique bon ça c'est lié à une
lésion au niveau du cerveau on en
reparlera peut-être une prochaine fois
si vous voulez alors attention ne vous
empêchez surtout pas de rigoler le rire
ça fait quand même beaucoup beaucoup
plus de bien que de mal ces cas-là c'est
quand même des trucs rarissibles voilà
bah écoutez dites-moi si ce format vous
a plu si vous en voulez d'autres et si
vous avez des questions auxquelles vous
voudriez que je réponde genre est-ce que
ça se peut de respirer par le tu sais
comme le pingouin il a envoyé moi tout
ça à question
dtc@gmail.com et tant que vous y êtes
abonnez-vous à mes réseaux sociaux parce
qu'il se passe plein de trucs par là-bas
aussi et qui va s'en passer de plus en
plus voilà DTC c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez-vous bien et surtout portez-vous
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]